hey what's up guys my name's samuel
leeds welcome back to q a sunday this
week i'm going to be answering
your property investment questions so if
you've got a question around property
whether it be around hmos lease option
agreements rent to rent packaging
selling deals structuring a joint
venture agreement what to look for in a
property or anything at all if you're
thinking about buying a house that
you're working at but you're trying to
work out is it a good deal is it a bad
deal post the details below in the
comment box and i'll do my very best to
answer your property investment
questions on my next q a sunday video
in the meantime i'm going to be
answering a few questions i'm going to
pick five top questions from last week's
q a sunday video and i'm going to be
answering those right here right now now
in order for me to answer your question
you do need to be a subscriber so you
know what do me a massive favor and do
yourself a favor and subscribe to the
channel i'm almost on
hundred thousand subscribers i think it
run like almost basically 199 so let's
try and get that to the 200 000 mark i
literally put a youtube video out every
single day and have been doing so for
years and i do that to try and help
people and give back to the property
community so go and hit subscribe smash
the like button share the positivity and
the love and drop your comment or
question below and i'll do my best to
answer so what we got so we've got a guy
called mephrooz raham said hi samuel i
just wanted to know
what would you do in my position
would you start investing into property
before having an emergency fund or
should you trust the investment to go
well
that's a really good question and i'm
going to answer that question in two
parts i'm gonna number one i'm gonna
tell you what
i would advise or what most people would
tell you is the right thing to do and
then i'm going to tell you what i did
okay so what most people would say and
you know if i was putting my sensible
hat on you'd say of course have an
emergency fund because if you invest all
your money into property and you haven't
got any cash in the bank you've not got
any cushion any oxygen because money is
oxygen money just makes things happen um
and you invest it all into property and
you stretch yourself then should an
emergency happen maybe you might have
something break in your house or you
might need an operation you have to pay
for you are over stretched over
leveraged and you can't afford to do it
so get your
emergency fund sorted make sure you've
got a little bit of cushion a few
thousand pounds in the bank and then
invest what's left into property that's
probably what most people advise you to
do that is however
not what i did myself and that's also
not what most people that i know who are
succeeding have done when they start out
most property investors most business
entrepreneurs they put everything on the
line
i did that
i was so stretched
i remember driving
at about 18 years old i remember driving
in my little ford purple ka and my car
was so low on petrol but i was like
i can't afford to get petrol because i
got no money in the bank i'm overdrawn
my credit cards are overdrawn and i
remember thinking i'm just gonna have to
make i need to get home
and wait for some rent to come in
because i've got a few properties right
now so i'm driving and guess what my car
broke down
i'm pushing my little ford bumped purple
ka to the nearest petrol station in the
rain i get to the petrol station i put
five pounds in because i can't afford
any more than five pounds just enough to
get me home
and i get to pay for the five pounds and
my card is declining because my credit
card and my overdraft is maxed out
i have to phone my little sister who's
four years younger than me who's like 15
years old and beggar to transfer five
pounds to my account so i can afford to
put some money in my car to get home
that that was me
and at the time i was buying houses i
had quite a few houses at that time so
for me to stand here and say to you
be sensible you know what if you want to
be ridiculously successful in this
business you can't be sensible you have
to be a little bit crazy you have to be
prepared to do things most often so i
couldn't advise you to do what i did
because some people would have a nervous
breakdown
but that's what i did
so i hope that helps answer your
question another thing is most people
say i'll make a nice salary
i'll save some money and then i'll
invest what's left over guess what's
going to be left over nothing
so you're better off to invest what you
can't afford to invest because at least
then it's invested and then you'll be
broke
good you'll be broke but you'll be
invested and then your rent comes in and
the properties appreciate i just had
some of my houses valued that i bought
back in those days i remember buying a
house when i was a teenager i just had
it valued this week and i'm like man
it's almost tripled in value
gone up doubled
and then tripled
in value and i get like a thousand pound
a month rent off of it not rent cash
flow profit so so glad that i stretched
myself 10 12 13 years ago because now
i'm reaping the rewards because i did
what most people weren't prepared to do
now i'm prepared to live how most people
can't live so hope that helps
all right next ms says hey samuel
awesome to see you're almost at 200 000
subscribers i'm so excited i'm like
refreshing it every day hoping that
another thousand people will subscribe
so pass this channel around to your
friends i've been on your q a since 2019
but have not started in property i hope
to start soon dude man you just have to
do it most people live their whole life
putting their foot on the accelerator
but also their spot on the brake because
they want to be everyone wants to be
comfortable everyone wants to be safe
listen every property investment going
gonna take some risk
everything you do is risky
having a job is risky investing in
property is risky leaving the house is
risky staying at home is risky
like
life's this risky none of us are gonna
get out alive
so
just stop pull the trigger anyway that
wasn't his question
you don't even got your question i'm
already giving you advice
i hope that's it my question this week
is
when viewing a possible deal what are
the top five things we should always
make sure of in terms of due diligence
also excited to meet you in december i'm
excited to meet you in december too what
are the things to look for the top five
things okay number one location
location's really important if you're
buying a property you need to make sure
that the area is not a terrible area
where you'll get stabbed on the viewing
you don't want
boarded up windows pimps and hoes in the
street you don't want that but you also
don't want
really nice beautiful all developed
because then there's no room for
generation and improvement so i tend to
go like three four out of ten also
location i like the outskirts of towns
where i can see that the returns good so
location's really important um
second thing is return on investment i
mean this is just mega you need to be
able you need to work out the numbers so
what's the return on investment i like
to make sure that return investment's
always a minimum of 15 percent um third
thing in terms of due diligence would be
maybe check
the actual house itself for structural
issues get a survey on the property make
sure that there's no rising damp there's
no mine shafts underneath the property
survey number four for due diligence
would be
uh what demographic kind of tenants are
you gonna get um you know who's gonna
manage the property uh who are you gonna
be putting in and then number five for
due diligence is can you add value i'd
be looking at how much value so if i buy
the property as it is today that's fine
that's one thing but what can i do to
the property that's going to add value
what how can i
um push the value up i like to buy the
the worst house on the best street i
don't mean the best street in in the
world i mean i'm gonna find a street
that's kind of average and i'm gonna buy
a property that's the worst on the
street because sometimes people buy
houses that have got ceiling prices so
they'll buy a house for 150 000 pounds
it's a little bit shabby
but even if you do it up and you spend
50 000 on it it's never gonna be more
than two hundred thousand pounds so i
like to buy a house in the street where
there's other houses selling for three
or four hundred thousand and i've got
mine for 150 so there's not the ceiling
price is not too low so i mean listen
there's a whole bunch of things there's
so many rules and if you're coming in
december to the training it's going to
blow your mind anyway what we got next
we got my man rahab says samuel i'm 19.
i'm currently working for people with
learning disabilities and i earn 9 pound
81 per hour how can i start a property
business i've watched your journey since
i was 18 and i and it grew my passion
for property business how can i join
your workshop to learn more and be
financially independent much love you're
my motivation firstly hey i appreciate
the support and i'm glad you've been
doing enjoying the youtube channel
here's this
it doesn't matter where you are it
doesn't matter what you do it doesn't
matter where you've been one thing
matters and that is where you're going
when you
yeah of course you can come on the train
it's free come meet me it'd be amazing
but what you'll find is when you come on
the train and there'll be a a solicitor
and a doctor
and a man that's just being made
redundant next to a woman that's been
made retire
retired next to a university student
next to a pregnant lady or a lady that's
on maternity doesn't want to go back to
work like everybo there's an equal
playing field everyone's from different
backgrounds different financial statuses
but it doesn't matter where you've been
or where you are it matters where you're
going so can you become successful in
property absolutely absolutely next
question joe stokes hi samuel what do
you spend your money on
what do i spend my money on
i spend my money on holidays i spend my
money on um
investing in myself on mentors coaches
experiences i like to spend my money on
experiences i'm not really too worried
about clothes or
material things it's more about learning
experiencing so yeah hotels we're going
to i'm going to dubai next month with my
beautiful wife we're going to be staying
in the burj al-arab which is not a
four-star hotel it's not a five-star
hotel it's not a six-hour start hotel
it's a seven star i mean i didn't even
know that existed so you know i just i
just like
experiences
so that's what i like to spend my money
on all right last question um kaja samir
mahudian mohammed said i really like
your videos i'd like to start my
property journey but i don't know much
about it i would like to invest 50 000
pounds i'm looking for any joint venture
partnership kindly help me or any
suggestions where i could invest my
money and get some profit in property
market okay so um kaja first thing i'll
say is
i wouldn't invest your 50 000 pounds
when you don't have a clue what you're
doing because it will go so much further
if you actually know what you're doing
the biggest thing you can do to begin
with is to invest a little bit of money
or time into your education because the
more you learn the more you earn as
cheesy as it sounds
fifty thousand pounds
if you spend fifty thousand pounds on
property investment but you don't know
what you're doing number one you could
lose the money you could mess it up
number two you could make money off of
it but not make as much money as you
could have done if you just spent one
thousand pounds investing in yourself
forty nine thousand pounds
will go a lot further than fifty
thousand pounds if in the hands of the
man that spent one thousand pounds
investing in himself first
think about that maybe play that back
anyway folks
i'm looking forward to seeing your
questions comment below any questions at
all i'll do my best to answer and um i
look forward to seeing you in person
come down to a crash course man come
down to one of our live training
programs i'll leave a link in the
description and see you soon peace out
god bless